- And now details on the sudden announcement that has captured the attention of the entire world.
Hidden among the countless billions of Wonka bars are five gold tickets,
and to the five people who find them will come the most fabulous prize one could wish for:
a lifetime supply of chocolate.
[Lightning Strikes]
- Nobody ever goes in,
nobody ever comes out.
[Eerie Music]
[Church bell rings]
[Children screaming playfully]
[Spooky orchestral music]
[Indistinct chattering]
- Hidden among the countless billions of
Wonka bars, are five gold tickets...
A lifetime supply of chocolate...
[Echoing] Chocolate...
[Edgy music]
[Distorted Laughter]
🎵[Slurred] Oh Danny boy🎵
🎵Danny boy🎵
🎵the pipes are calling🎵
[Whistling]
[Knife unsheathing]
- MINE!
[Coins clattering]
Look, everyone! Look!
I found some money in the street and I bought a Wonka bar, and a ticket was in it!
- Charlie-
- Look at it, Grandpa. See for yourself.
- "Present this ticket at the factory gates at 10 o'clock in the morning of the first day of October and do not be late."
- It's nice to have you here,
I'm so glad you could come.
This is going to be such an exciting day.
I hope you enjoy it,
I think you will.
You are now about to enter the nerve center
to the entire Wonka factory.
Inside this room all of my dreams become realities.
- Grandpa, look over there, across the river!
They're little men!
- Jumping crocodiles, Charlie!
Now we know who makes the chocolate.
[Screaming]
- It looks like he's drowning...
- Dive in!
Save him!
He can't swim!
- Watch the pipe.
[Screaming]
Terrific pressure is building up behind the blockage.
[Gurgling]
The suspense is terrible.
[Gurgling mixed with strained screaming]
- My son!
You terrible man!
🎵🎵🎵
- You got a garbage strike going on here, Wonka?
- Who wants an everlasting gobstopper?
- Me!
Me! I do!
- I can only give them to you if you solemnly swear to keep them to-
- I don't care!
- Violet, now don't you do anything stupid.
- It's tomato soup!
- Violet! You're turning violet, Violet!
- What's happening?
- You're blowing up like a balloon!
🎵Oompa Loompa🎵
HELP!
🎵Doompadee Doo🎵
🎵I've got a perfect puzzle for you🎵
🎵Oompa Loompa🎵
[Screaming]
🎵Doompadee Dee🎵
🎵 If you are wise🎵
🎵You'll listen to me🎵
🎵🎵🎵
- Well, well, well, two naughty nasty little children gone!
Three children left
These are the geese that lay the golden eggs,
as you can see, they're larger than ordinary geese.
- Hey, Daddy, I want a golden goose!
- Here we go again...
- How much do you want for the golden goose?
- They're not for sale.
- Name your price.
- She can't have one.
- I want one!
I want a golden go-
[Screams]
[Bones cracking mixed with smashes]
[Loud smash]
- She was a bad egg.
Now would you all please put these on?
There's dangerous stuff inside.
Wonkavision!
My very latest and greatest invention!
LIGHTS...
CAMERA...
ACTION!
- AAH!
- Here it comes...
There it is.
- It's real!
- Taste it, It's delicious!
It's just gotten smaller, that's all.
- Look at me!
I'm going to be the first person in the
world to be sent by television!
- Mike, get away from that thing!
- Stop. Don't.
Come back.
- AAH!
Mike!
- Flying over our heads in a million pieces.
- Where are you?
- Now watch the screen.
[Screaming]
- You call that unharmed?
[Gurgling]
- Adieu,
Parting is such sweet sorrow.
- You're a cheat and a swindler,
how can you do a thing like this?
- Excuse me for not showing you out,
straight up the stairs
You'll find the way,
and goodbye to you both. Goodbye.
- Let's take a drink, Charlie
Nobody's watching.
- Yeah.
- A small one won't hurt us.
- You lose!
[Screaming]
- Hey, Grandpa, I can't get down!
Help!
Grandpa, the fan!
- Stay away from it, Charlie!
It will chop us to bits!
We're in trouble, Charlie!
I can't stop!
- It's pulling me in!
- I can't stop!
I can't stop!
- What do we do?
There's nothing to grab on to!
Help!
We're going to get killed!
- Help! Help!
- Help!
- Mr. Wonka, please turn off the fan! OH!
No!
Help!
🎵Oompa Loompa🎵
🎵Doompadee Doo🎵
Looking for a reason to subscribe?
Well, how about action?
No!
Subscribe for horror
I saw someone die late last night
She followed me here
Then show her to me
Look behind you
Or just subscribe to join the party
Don't miss out